let's go next to our caller from the 6-5
zero area code who's calling today from
six five zero hi okay hey Jose what's
going on International from from Mexico
yep and I was just wondering whether you
managed to see the new ruling from ice
the Trump administration that is just
making it pretty hard for international
students get back in the States
yeah unless universities bend over
backwards so I did see it
III did see it I'm I'm against the the
ruling if you know how can it be that
it's safe enough to open all elementary
and high schools and yet it is too
dangerous to allow a relatively modest
number of international students to come
in it strikes me as discriminatory like
either it's safe to do schools or it's
not as my take but I heard and I've not
read a lot into this you maybe know more
about this than I do that if schools say
that they've assigned an individual
teacher to you for in-person learning
which can just be like a five-minute
check-in per week that technically then
the students would be allowed to come in
have you heard anything about that yeah
we have to take a certain number of
credit hours as in person or like hybrid
right in order for us to be able to take
like the rest of our course load online
yeah it I mean it just seems to have a
lot of loopholes in it and to me it just
seems like a strategy to get schools to
reopen forcibly because I just I mean
I'm studying computer science and like I
can't imagine the computer science
department at my university operating
without international students right
like they're the DA's they are at look
like they worked student officers like I
did yeah it's just it's very draconian
that seems counterproductive well it
seems to me that either way it will give
the Trump the Trump administration's
something that they like either they
will keep keep a bunch of foreigners out
that's one possibility and they would
welcome that or it would get schools to
reopen even when they don't really think
it's the right thing to do which is also
what the Trump administration wants so
it's almost like they're gonna get
something they like out of this no I
agreed what do you think of the end game
of of opening schools it just seems like
a bomb right they explode like you get
you have a bunch of cases individual
household you send all the kids to the
same place I'll get infected and then
they all go back home yeah I think we I
think basically the the hope is the bomb
won't go off until after November 3rd
like I think the calculation is schools
won't I believe that no schools open
earlier than late August here in
Massachusetts it's usually September I
think there's some states that open
earlier I think the calculation is if we
get schools open we get the publicity of
schools being open parents are able to
go back to their jobs maybe because
they're not home watching their kids so
the economy will show some better jobs
numbers and hopefully it'll all stay
relatively under control until November
3rd and it'll get Trump reelected I
don't think it'll work I mean if you
look at we it's right now as we're
filming this it's the early afternoon we
already are at 25,000 new cases today
it's only halfway through the day most
states don't report until the afternoon
like it seems like it's not going to
work but I think that's their idea it's
crazy it's crazy all right my friend I
hope it works out and I appreciate you
letting me know what's going on okay
take care of likewise the pleasure is
all on this side of the microphone